hey 42 here when we think of clowns
several images come to mind beloved
entertainers who bring joy to your
children
fast food mascots you'd never consider
trusting with your children
and bloodthirsty supernatural entities
who are probably planning to eat your
children
but even if there's nothing you love
better than a red-nosed idiot in baggy
clothes
it's hard to deny that clowns can be
terrifying
but for some people this fear can be
quite intense
and they'd give a warmer welcome to the
bubonic plague than they would to a
traveling circus
this overwhelming fear of clowns is
known as culrophobia
taken from the ancient greek word
kulrope meaning
one who goes on stilts so if you don't
already have a fear of clowns
just for a few seconds imagine a 10-foot
monster with a crimson smile
looming over you whilst you sleep you're
welcome
the term was first used around 1980 and
although the world health organization
doesn't officially recognize it as a
phobia
you don't have to look too hard to find
evidence for it
when the world's oldest clown creaky
creekmore
died back in 2014 the response on
facebook and twitter
was mixed and that's putting it mildly
there were many posts praising creaky
for all the charity work he'd done over
his 98
years but plenty of other people took
the news as an opportunity to tell the
world
just how much creaky creeped them out
and how much they hated clowns in
general there's just something about
clowns that drains people of sympathy
and fills them with terror psychiatrists
say that whilst
true colorophobia is rare it's more
common today
than it once was and it's not unusual
for sufferers to go huge lumps to avoid
being anywhere
they could bump into a clown however if
they do accidentally wander into
a circus and find themselves face to
face with their worst nightmare
they may experience a number of physical
symptoms like
nausea sweating crying screaming
even difficulty breathing sounds a bit
like me after i listened to radio 1 for
10 minutes
but why clowns what is it about them
that freaks us out
well colorphobia is thought to be
connected with the uncanny valley effect
where we feel unsettled by things that
appear human but are just
a little bit off human looking robots
for instance or ventriloquists dummies
or zombies or michael jackson
it's the way they move or smile or feast
on your brains
or grab their crotch and scream in the
middle of a song
it's just not right it interrupts the
pattern your brain is used to
making you feel uneasy and it's exactly
the same with clowns
they have painted on smiles but their
real mouths might frown
or scowl or grimace and your brain just
doesn't know how to deal with that
humans gather a huge amount of
information from facial expressions
and if that information gets smothered
beneath a half inch of grease
paint the system just goes haywire oh
and then there's the red nose of course
what the holy hell is all that about
another theory is that the slightly off
appearance of clowns makes us think of
death
the face of a corpse for instance looks
almost like a sleeping face
but somehow we can just tell as
something different
and that bothers us and it's not just
clown faces that make us whimper and
crawl into a fetal position
because humans are also very sensitive
to body language clowns
walk in a weird way with their huge
floppy shoes
have an unusual posture fall over a lot
and just can't seem to resist cramming
themselves into tiny little cars
and it's inconsistent stimuli like these
that are the problem we're hardwired to
distrust
the weird guy on the bus the drunk guy
in the middle of the street
the maniac in face paint squirting water
at us for a flower
anything that doesn't fit our normal
view of the world
is automatically viewed as a threat even
if all it's doing is making balloon
animals
and laughing a bit too much coulrophobia
also ties in with social anxiety
because we generally only see clowns in
a social context
or at least we bloody well should do if
you stumble across one in your basement
then social anxiety is the least of your
worries
most people have a genuine fear of being
mocked by others
or picked out from the crowd but just
how much of a part this plays in
colorophobia isn't clear
after all this kind of social anxiety is
common in other settings as well
most people would rather soil themselves
and get up and go to the toilet
during a comedian's set but i'm fairly
sure
comedophobia isn't a thing whatever the
cause of coulrophobia
it clearly affects some people more than
others it's thought our fear of clown
stems from our childhood
which is peak clown exposure time for
most people
according to psychology professor joseph
derwin of california state
university young children are very
reactive to a familiar body type
with an unfamiliar face which is why
hiring a clown to visit your sick child
could be about as sensible as hiring
colonel sanders to visit your sick
chicken
that sentiment is backed up by perhaps
the most well-known study of
coulrophobia
which was conducted by the university of
sheffield in 2008.
250 children were asked how they felt
about a hospital ward being decorated
with images of clowns the results
were pretty clear suggesting clowns were
universally disliked by children
with some finding them frightening and
unknowable
so fyi hospital clown might not be the
best line of work to get
into these days not that it seems to
have helped patch adams back
when robin williams plays you in the
film of your life you've probably done
something right
the weird thing is some people who never
saw a clown in their young lives
still lose control of their bowels every
time they drive past a circus
so what's going on there well evidence
suggests
phobias can be learnt from your parents
which might help explain
why the fear of clowns is still going
strong today despite
travelling circuses becoming less and
less common
in many parts of the world thanks for
that mum and dad
it's most likely however that in order
to create a truly delicious colorophobia
stew
your childhood experiences are mixed in
with various
terrifying pop culture depictions of
clowns peppered with nightmares and then
baked for a couple of decades on a low
heat until you're truly phobic
i mean just think about how many weird
clowns we've seen in films and tv shows
over the years
we had 1988's killer clowns from outer
space
in which alien clowns massacre their
victims before cocooning them
in cussing candy we've had heath
ledger's joker
a character who had many dark layers to
him not least because ledger tragically
died shortly after filming his betrayal
oh and for any 1970s kids watching this
video
we should probably mention sal clemenson
guitarist for the sensational
alex harvey band who wore black and
white clown makeup on stage
along with colourful body suits despite
the band's comedic
overtones clemenson's happy sad demeanor
certainly gave the performance a hint of
menace and that's before you throw their
version of tom jones's delilah into the
mix
benjamin radford author of the 2016 book
bad clowns claims sinister clowns have
not only existed throughout our history
including harlequin
the king's fool and mr punch but also
suggests they've evolved into our modern
day
internet trolls just like their
ancestors
trolls abuse tease and play with people
for their own amusement
and as someone who's read his fair share
of youtube comments i wholeheartedly
endorse this theory
we don't quite know where the evil clown
thing started
but it certainly goes back hundreds of
years at least
there's edgar allan poe's story hop frog
which is based on a jester
and leon cavallo's opera pagliacci
features several murderous clowns but
andrew stott professor of english at the
university of buffalo
argues the very first scary clown can be
found in
the pitwick papers by charles dickens in
one chapter of the book dickens
describes a clown as having
a bloated body and trunk and legs their
deformity enhanced a hundredfold by
their fantastic dress
the glassy eyes contrasting fearfully
with the thick
white paint with which the face was
besmeared
the grotesquely ornamental head
trembling with paralysis
and the long skinny hands rubbed with
white
chalk all gave him a hideous and
unnatural appearance
wow doesn't he sound like fun perfect
for your five-year-old's birthday party
starts believes dickens was inspired by
joseph grimaldi
the father of modern clowning which
makes sense because he edited grimaldi's
memoirs around the same time
grimaldi created the character joey in
the early 1800s
and is thought to be the first clown to
wear white face makeup
along with the huge painted on smile
brightly coloured hair
and over-the-top costume grimaldi
however was much more loved than dickens
macabre creation
in fact annual remembrance services are
still held for him
at all saints church in haggerston east
london so
there's another place to avoid if you
aren't a fan of clowns
but how did we get from the much-loved
grimaldi to our modern day
evil clowns one person who booked the
trend was emmett
kelly who based his sad clown weary
willy
on depression era tramps with a painted
on smile that wasn't a smile at all but
a very distinct
frown and then there's tv clown bozo
he was very popular with children in the
50s and 60s
and maybe it's a generational thing but
just take a good look at him
don't you get the feeling he could snap
at any moment and start feasting on your
internal organs
maybe it's just me from bozo it's easy
to see a connection with ronald mcdonald
that's
terrifying pied piper style clown whose
sole mission in life was to lead
children to a mystical mountain of
cheeseburgers
in the land of coronary artery disease
in the early 21st century it was
estimated that more than 95 percent of
american children
recognized him which led to concerns
about childhood obesity
and is one of the reasons he doesn't
tend to appear in adverts anymore
well that and the fact that he's clearly
a demon straight from the nine circle of
hell
with a terrifying death mask for her
face and a flagrant disregard for the
benefits of a balanced diet
one man who did nothing to help the
reputation of clowns was john wayne gacy
a notorious serial killer who sexually
assaulted and murdered at least 33 young
men and boys
before burying them in the crawl space
underneath his house
in 1975 gacy became a member of the
jolly joker clown club
and created two characters for himself
pogo
who he described as a happy clown and
patchers
he was significantly more serious gacy
never carried out his crimes in costume
but that didn't stop the media dubbing
him the killer clown
and giving culrophobes yes another
reason to double check the lock on the
front door
before going to bed each night and of
course how could i make a video about
coulrophobia
and evil clowns without mentioning the
king
stephen king and his terrifying creation
pennywise the dancing clown king's epic
novel
it was published in 1986 and has since
passed into scary clown legend
mostly manifesting is pennywise it is
actually an
ancient cosmic entity which awakens once
every generation
to feed upon the children of derry maine
it's easy to draw a parallel between
pennywise and
john wayne gacy of course but king has
never mentioned him in connection with
the character
in fact king was originally inspired by
the children's tale free billy goats
gruff
but rather than a troll under a bridge
he wanted to write about some other kind
of creature inhabiting the sewer system
and
when he asked himself what scared
children more than anything else in the
world
there was only one answer clowns the
book was followed by a 1990 tv
miniseries starring tim curry as a very
bozo inspired pennywise
and the recent films featuring bill
skarsgard's equally horrifying portrayal
oh and just to get your coulrophobia
juices flowing even more
pennywise comes out to feed every 27
years
and the movie was made in 2017
27 years after the original miniseries
you're welcome a year before it hit the
cinemas
clown sighting suddenly became a very
common and
unnerving experience with the advent of
the great
clown panic of 2016
but phantom clowns have been
sporadically spotted around the world
for decades the 1980s saw multiple
reports made by children
claiming men in clown suits had
attempted to lure them into a van
which spread panic across the usa and on
the other side of the atlantic in 2013
a clown was spotted in various locations
around northampton
standing perfectly still and silent and
generally freaking people the hell out
it turned out to be the work of free
students having a bit of fun
but unsurprisingly a bunch of youtubers
took inspiration from the stunt
dressing up as killer clowns and scaring
the bejesus out of the general public
gaining millions of views in the process
i mean
what kind of youtuber would do something
like that just for views
the first of the 2016 sightings was
reported in green bay wisconsin
in early august when pictures of a
creepy clown in an empty parking lot
went viral
a facebook page went up proclaiming the
clown was called gags
and although it later turned out to be a
publicity stunt for a horror film
the craze had already started to spread
in south carolina a nine-year-old boy
told his mother that two men dressed as
clowns
tried to lure him into the woods and by
october clown sightings have been
reported
all over the states canada the uk
australia
and in 16 other countries people were
genuinely terrified
president of the world clown association
yes that's a thing
randy christensen took a very public
stance against
the trend not least because circuses and
other clown related businesses were
negatively affected
professional clowns intensely dislike
the evil clown persona
for obvious reasons and have no desire
to add to the growing issue of
coulrophobia
it even got to the point where several
news outlets reported the possibility of
a
clown purge or attack on the eve of
halloween which led to some florida
residents
packing heat when they went
trick-or-treating
as it turned out a widespread clown
apocalypse
never came but one family was attacked
on halloween night by 20 people in clown
masks
so maybe the guns weren't such a bad
idea after all
so yes the events of 2016 certainly
weren't a great help to anyone suffering
from coulrophobia
in fact for them it was probably a worse
year than 2020's been for the rest of us
but the important thing to remember is
that most clowns are completely harmless
and there's absolutely no reason to be
scared of them no reason at all
even if you're in bed one night in the
dark on your own
and you suddenly hear the flop of a
massive shoe downstairs
followed by the pop of a red nose even
if you're busy recording a youtube video
and
wait did you hear that